friends he only eats grass-fed beef
and here's the weird thing cows eat
grass that's what we've messed with our
food when something eats what it's
supposed to we brag about it that's like
saying hey you know my four-year-old is
sober
[Music]
Mark Normand is a late night talk show
favorite regularly guesting on Conan
Colbert and Jimmy Fallon my biggest fear
used to be the bar closing that was like
my biggest fear now my biggest fear is
my phone dying yeah which is pretty good
100 years ago we had real problems my
baby's got the black lungs she might not
make it through the night I'm like I'm a
two percent I might actually have to
feel something
yeah
you might even find the award-winning
stand-up sitting down with the likes of
Joe Rogan spinning Yarns for his wildly
popular podcast how many times you guys
think you're rubbed oh I mean you get
robbed real good like six times a year
oh yeah oh yeah but right now he's right
here ready to finally make his New
Zealand debut thanks a lot
[Applause]
thank you I've been Kevin Hart um you're
not obviously but I know when I've got a
gig that's not going well I say thanks
I've been Jesse Mulligan
[Music]
well I would bomb so much that I had to
use another guy's name because I was so
embarrassed to say my own I've heard it
done you've turned it into a trademark
now people expect it yeah Kevin Hart
hates it
and also we are renowned for our
grain-fed beef here in New Zealand do
you think it may be trust-fed beef yeah
grass-fed sorry yeah as opposed to grain
fit sure yeah that's our thing but I
don't know I mean you saw the joke it's
just silly because
yeah and that's how much we mess with
our food that when they eat what they
were supposed to we brag about it you
know it's like saying hey my
four-year-old is sober
we're talking about family dinners
earlier do you remember much about
growing up having dinner around the
table what was your upbringing like I
blocked most of it out a lot of drinking
a lot of domestic abuse my mom was very
angry but uh no no we did it and it was
it was nice it's awkward but you got to
do it yeah it sounds like you had to do
it pretty tough
um growing up oh it was fine I was
actually raised by a drag queen my
parents hired a drag queen so they were
ahead of the game
but it was a weird childhood and now I
can't get an erection unless I see a
picture of RuPaul
[Laughter]
you made short films and wet the bed as
a child oh big bed wetter my mattress
looked like a coffee filter
old pirate map you know it was brown and
lines and I had the uh the plastic wrap
on my bed and it's so embarrassing when
in the bed that your friends would sit
on the bed and go what the hell is this
plastic and I was like uh I'm a murderer
yeah way better than a bedwetter but
I've urinated um I'm like R Kelly
[Laughter]
[Music]
you have been to been to Australia and
I'm sorry but you're here now yeah you
did catch a little bit of the Aussie
rules are you gonna catch up with some
of our rugby big semi-finals this
weekend
[Music]
I see the game that makes no sense yeah
yeah boy it was uh it's very Harry
Pottery you know British and when you
score a goal they go
it was silly but even if even if you
missed the goal you get points yeah so
Australian the problem was the meat pies
I had two of those and I've just ruined
my pants
if you can get a whimper there no a
little bit actually I was wondering I'm
sorry I know you also you've talked
about carrying around your wad of jokes
yeah um have you got it with you now
would you is that well I slimmed it down
because I was mocked so mercilessly on
the internet though I cut it I cut it in
half oh my God these are these ideas
that you write down as you go these are
mostly swastika because I've drawn
this is all Australia stuff that I wrote
down but it's too inappropriate for this
but I don't want to do it right now yeah
but yeah that's it you know on a 20 20
hour flight I would get a bad back you
just grab whatever papers available and
write down the the idea that you've had
and where you go that's exactly most of
it's horrible
um well it's great to have you in New
Zealand you're playing the North Shore
the Bruce Mason theater if you'd like to
see Mark the tour is this Thursday at
Auckland and details on our Facebook
page for Mark Norman
now
[Music]